i've been dying to talk about this for
days okay look here's the thing man here
is the thing man y'all are ready man
okay no spoilers no spoilers
man
man dude okay here's the thing man this
movie like i know i should record at the
office right check it here's here's kind
of what my home looks like those you
guys who aren't really familiar with uh
with with my place this is a little bit
of a setup tour a little bit of setup
tour going on
man y'all
y'all are ready
y'all are ready son this movie man this
movie's on a whole another level son it
is
damn okay okay here's here's okay no
spoilers here's one thing i'll give you
guys here's one thing i will give you
guys
with the exception of the great big huge
fight sequence and electro
pretty much everything you've seen in
the trailer happens in the first 30
minutes
let that sink in
man this movie
man
man
dude this it's it's i'm telling you guys
right now man like i think this movie is
better than infinity war and avengers
in-game it's it's
man i wish i could spoil stuff okay
we'll do we'll do like the spoiler
review later right we'll do that at like
the end of the week right for right now
this is just this this is an answer to
the question should you be hyped about
spider-man no way home
son man it is
if god was making spider-man movies
right now this is what it will look like
right now
it's nuts it's it's it's amazing it's
the do the pacing the storytelling man
the cure
it's it's man it is uh
the fight sequences are
mind-blowing right it's just it's crazy
it's it's absolutely mind-blowing um
it's
all the rumors out there like all the
things out there people were saying that
this feels like spider-man in-game they
were not wrong they they're they're
they're 100 right uh okay we we we can't
go on too much longer because i feel
like if we do we're gonna end up
spoiling stuff um
i will say this as with every single
movie the answer for why it is the
villains are appearing in the marvel
cinematic universe is much simpler than
you thought it was and as soon as you
get the explanation for why it's
happening you're gonna be like of course
man
of course like why didn't i think of it
i'm sure some of you guys probably did
but like most people just didn't think
of it right it's just one of those
things where it just it never crossed
their minds either because it was just
too simple or whatever but like it's
it's the simplest explanation right it's
it's the marvel cinematic universe rule
right the simplest explanation tends to
be the right one also known as occam's
razor but the important thing is this
this this movie
y'all aren't ready man
y'all are not ready for this movie
coming out chill y'all ain't ready for
this man y'all are not ready for this
film it's gonna blow people's minds um
from what i understand right now it's
got a 100 on rotten tomatoes well earned
it is
it's great spoiler free review this
movie is lit
oh it's lit it's it's a me it's gonna be
it's it's good
it's good i don't know how well this
performs in terms of like a spoiler-free
review i don't know how to do a
spoiler-free review guys i'm sorry i
don't know how to do a spoiler free
review right the only reviews i know how
to do are just like here's all the
things that happened in the movie and
here are the best parts i don't know i
don't know how to do a spoiler free
review outside of saying the movie's lit
but hopefully this video gets you hyped
up man because
it's it's it's got some phenomenal
moments in here um there are huge
surprises
and and i hate to kind of use a trope
and say like it's gonna change things
but you're gonna walk out of this movie
and just kind of be like damn where do
they go from here like it's it's it's
great post credit scenes stick around
for those stick around for those anyway
guys uh yes i'm excited
this movie was phenomenal i hope you
guys are excited
and i will catch you all later
peace